okay so we'll be going live in three two
one
okay
okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards and I will be chairing this
evening's meeting
um could I please ask uh first of all if
you could turn your phones off or at the
very least of Silence I appreciate some
people might need to make emergency uh
texts or calls so at the very least
silent but preferably off as long as
they don't interrupt the flow of the
meeting I'm perfectly comfortable
um we're not expecting a fire alarm if a
fire alarm does go off please follow us
slowly across the car park over the road
we will check your names off against
register to make sure everyone's got out
the building
itself is a meeting in public it is not
a public meeting so only those people
that have registered to speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I'll call you forward to one of the
three desks in front of us if you press
the button in the middle of the
microphone it will turn red and you will
be live
um and again obviously if you press it
again it will turn it off
um I will obviously let you know your
allocated time when you are sat down
um and if you could say seated with
questions afterwards that would be great
let me introduce our officers if I may
so to my far right we have Howard
Allison from our committee Services team
we have Sue Mullins to my immediate
right who is our solicitor and our
planners in no particular order are Tony
Horton uh Victoria Kempton Rhino Keith
and we have Ben Ellis joining us from
the environmental health Team and we
also have Richard Gardner who is to my
immediate left is our planning manager
and I believe Richard you have a
statement to make
uh thank you Mr chairman good evening
everyone this is just to confirm that my
role tonight is to provide impartial
advice and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you thank you very
much indeed let's dive into the meeting
itself so a first item is a produce for
absence Howard do we have any apologies
please
uh yes chair we have apologies from
councilor Kendall councilor Foreman
councilor Rock for whom councilor Adam
is substituting
marvelous thank you very much welcome
councilor Adam disclosures of Interest
members anyone have any disclosures
Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman yes um
item for the agenda land adjacent to the
old gagey road Banbury Road Upper light
Hall
um I'm the County Council for this uh
division
um but um I come to this with an open
mind Mr chairman on this one and also uh
I had some five on the agenda I'm
actually the ward member for here but
I've not entered it into any discussion
whatsoever with anybody on this so I
feel like I can sit on the panel with an
open mind
and the discussion Mr chairman okay
lovely stuff anyone else
no um I have received I don't know if
you'll have a letter from upper
lighthorne Parish Council it has been
addressed to all planning committee
members
I have people received that we should be
letting that people know that so I'm
gonna assume everyone has received that
is that a fair assessment grab quick
show hands if you have everyone happy
with that yeah so if we can do a blanket
one for that that would be great
laughs
foreign
a quick question for you if I may I
believe you might have made
um a declaration of interest on the
application for so item four application
2201385 vary this is upper Litecoin
application and you step down at the
last committee meeting will you be doing
that again this time um no Mr chairman
not not this particular application
though are you comfortable that you've
declared an interest on the same item a
month ago and you're not now declaring
that interest now that's a totally
different uh
okay if you're comfortable yeah that's
fine
um okay minutes is everyone happy with
the minutes as set out in the
agenda pack I was fabulous I will sign
those afterwards right in that case
let's move to our first application of
the evening which is application of
2201385 very that is land adjacent to
the old gated Road Banbury Road and
upper light on our presenting officer is
Tony Horton Tony over to you
like a chairman
this is the context map for the
application so it's a part where the
black dot is that's part of the upper
light or new settlement formally
referred to as Gayden lights on Heath or
glh
now this part is owned by homes England
and there's outline permission for up to
a thousand dwellings
the land further to the South here is
also part of the upper light on new
settlements that's landowned by ceg and
a Consortium of house builders and
that's got plenty of permission for up
to 2 000 dwellings and a new Village
Center
show you the site in a bit more detail
this is the homes England site the M40
Motorway running to the north there the
old gated Road
to the side here Chesterton Woods at the
frontage you've got the b4100 Banbury
Road
then you've got the edge of the phase
one of the new settlement here by belway
homes the land here is Kingston Fields
Farm which was that committee a few
weeks ago if you recall that
across the sides there is a public
right-of-way which then crosses the
motorway here
so outline planning permissions being
granted for the up to 1000 dwellings
we've also granted Reserve matters
approval for the green infrastructure so
these are all these green elements that
you can see on this screen
infrastructure plan
the white elements are the part the
development Parcels which have yet to
come forward other than this parcel one
which is a separate Reserve matter
so previously a bond along the M40 has
been granted approved through the
reserve matters process and the
application before members this evening
and are shown on this plan is to have
the same Bond but to take away a two
meter high fence that was previously
approved there
I'll now run through a series of typical
cross-sections so
there'll be a one at the Northern end
here
one in the central area and then one at
the southern end so at the Northern end
where the site is at its lowest point
you can see that on the M40 side here
the embankment of the bond is going to
be quite considerable up to 13 meters
and then we've got a width of around
about 44 meters of the base of the bond
so it's a considerable structure
Central typical cross-section
this shows from the motorway side around
about a 10 meter height of bond
and we're around about 38 meters of the
base of the bond there
and then at the southern end where the
site is at its highest
we're down to about eight meters is
needed for the bond from the M40 side
and we're going around about 37 meters
across on the base of the bond
so and I'll show you a photograph which
is taken from Chesterton windmill grade
one listed building and a scheduled
Monument
and so the views from that Vantage Point
are one of the key elements that we
would take into consideration when it
comes to the the impact of the bond
so to orientate itself Chesterton Woods
there this sliver of green land that you
can see there is the Holmes England site
and then the M40 Motorway is running in
a cutting in between there so the Bond
as as much as you could see it uh we're
at a distance about 1.8 kilometers here
would be in that
General locations so the
um the question is whether or not the
removal of the fence and the bond
provision they're taking the bond off
whether that has any material
implications for the the setting of that
Heritage asset
moving on to another photograph this is
taken from the northern
M40 Motorway Bridge so this is where the
old gated Road crosses the M40 so we're
looking at back across to the homes
England site you can see there's quite a
wide verge of the M40 there so the bond
starts the other side of the fence
that's there and so it will run parallel
to the motorway
and then photograph taken from the
southern Bridge so that's where the
public right away crosses over
so you can see this is the homes England
side so the bond will run parallel to
the verge of the motorway going going
down there and as explained earlier
because of the levels difference is the
the height of the bond will vary
depending on the need to mitigate the
noise from the motorway
and then finally an aerial view of the
Holmes England site
so just to warranty itself the B for 100
Banbury Road Chesterton Woods old gated
road then we've got the M40 and the
noise Bond runs parallel to that
I think chairman that's all I need to
show in terms of
um the presentation at this moment in
time
thank you very much indeed let's pull
forward our first Speaker who is
councilor Hannah hedger from upper light
horn Parish Council good evening
councilor hedger and welcome
so when you're comfortable and seated uh
red button you've already got there
you've done it before you'll have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning when you before your time's up
um otherwise when you're ready the floor
is yours okay good evening everyone
um I'm here to representative light
storm Parish Council and specifically
here to represent our future
parishioners who will occupy the new
settlement of our political and
particularly those parishioners who will
live closest to the noise fund
you will recall from the previous
meeting where you objected to the
application for the removal of the
acoustic fence as we feel that this is a
dilution of the noise mitigation levels
which parish councils fought long and
hard for during the process of glh in
the course strategy
since the last meeting we've worked with
Stratford District Council in homes
England to seek assurances that once the
houses have been built Parish councils
will have for Parish councils will be
assured that further mandatory testing
is completed in order to ensure that
there's compliance with World Health
Organization regulations
whilst we've been offered Solutions when
houses have been built this this still
leaves the onus on Parish councils to
Monitor and indeed the residents
themselves to seek Solutions via
enforcement
all we're asking for is that a mandated
condition is attached to this
application to ensure that testing is
carried out once the houses have been
built and that there isn't a need for
Parish cancers to monitor or indeed
residents themselves to have to work
through a protective protracted process
of enforcement
okay
councilor thank you very much well
within your time members do we have any
questions for councilor hedger please
councilman Curtis thank you very much
thank you
um the the testing who can ask who the
parish council would like to see or
would expect to carry out that test we
would expect the homes England
thank you
anyone else
no thank you very much for your time
contribution this evening
and we'll call our second speaker of the
evening who is councilor Andy Smith
chairman of lighthorne Parish Council
that's quite all right we can definitely
see you so that's a good thing
um councilor Smith in the same event
you'll have three minutes I'll give you
30 second warning before your time is up
but whenever you're ready the floor is
yours today
so this comes down to a Reliance on
predicted noise levels being no
substitute for testing actual noise
levels extensive testing has been
carried out before the noise Bund has
been constructed and detailed reports
showing predicted noise levels have been
submitted all we ask is that at some
point after the noise band and the
closest houses have been constructed
further testing is mandated to ensure
that noise levels are within who
recommended levels we do not understand
the reluctance to introduce a condition
requiring this
it is suggested that future Reserve
matters applications might be able to
have a condition attached requiring
further testing but no Assurance of this
is being given
this application seeking to remove the
obligation of a noise fence will be a
distant memory when such applications
are considered
the developers report asserts that
excessive noise can be addressed by
sdc's enforcement policy but enforcement
is a discretionary service and we doubt
that it has the teeth to ensure
effective remedy if noise levels are
found to be excessive
we ask the planning committee to
consider ways in which a few in which
future residents can be effectively
protected against the circumstance where
proposed noise mitigations turn out to
be insufficient
Pastor Smith thank you very much indeed
remember councilor Parry please
good evening councilor Smith I just
wondered whether you
I mean this may well be a question for
officers but do you do you have any
information as to when the testing was
carried out whether it was raining or
whether it was in the summer with dry
weather uh someone who lives fairly near
to the M40
noise from a Motorway is much louder
during wet conditions and is very much
dependent on the Wind as it is from
sunny
warm climate conditions
Council Smith what do you answer if you
wouldn't mind turning your microphone
back on that's correct thank you I don't
have that knowledge sorry
thank you
um any other questions for Council Smith
please
no council Smith thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
okay our final speaker on this item is
uh Mr Ragu satambalam
good evening I hope I said that right
I've practiced it all afternoon
so you will have six minutes feel free
to use as much as little as you like and
I'll give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up you've got some stuff to
go on the slide yeah
um now do you want us do you want to
give us a notification when you want the
slide to move on or do the next slide
please thank you
foreign
work in planning and enabling at homes
England
um we act as the government's housing
estate housing accelerator to deliver
new homes
um sorry next slide please
um so this is our site known as landed
light horn Heap on our systems but what
we call Windmill viewer polite horn
um it's got online consent for a
thousand homes retail community building
and playing pictures and we've committed
to spending over 12 million pounds to
facilitate delivery of site-wide
infrastructure Landscaping utilities and
we've got a view to extend that further
sorry next slide please
um so today for context what we're
talking about if you can click it one
more time
um
is the removal of an acoustic fence
across um the north side of our site
which faces onto the M40 and it's a 950
meters in length and it's just shown in
red there sorry hex load please
um in places the bundle be over 10
meters high measured from the M40 which
acts as the principal noise also we're
trying to deal with here on the left
hand side you have the modeling to
illustrate how the noise will be
dispersed with the fence and on the
right hand side without the fence and
the point here is with this Amber yellow
green and to demonstrate that the
acoustic mitigation required for the
design of the properties is the same in
both instances so if you look at that
green area in between the bundle and the
dwellings that's exactly the same and
that's how that conclusion is reached in
in the officer report
sorry next slide please
um so just to illustrate the visual
change that will occur through the
construction of the bond and this image
shows the site looking South
um from the north side of the M40 and we
know that in the offset balance there
isn't considered to be a visual benefit
raised um from the removal of the fence
and we acknowledge that this is a matter
for the LPA to decide next slide please
um so this is an uh well again so we're
just showing what this would look like
so this is based on the actual levels
provided from our ground modeling and
it's really just to demonstrate the
extent of How High the bundle will
appear and um on top of this you'll see
from the officer report that we've
agreed to an additional condition for a
revised planting scheme in place of the
place of the fence to ensure that we
enhance the visual appearance uplift our
site-wide biodiversity net gain and also
provide a limited approve Improvement in
acoustic performance and through the
introduction of the Hedgerow sorry next
slide please
um so beyond this uh this slide sets out
some options that we provided to the
parish councils about possible options
that we could Implement to deal with the
revive planting scheme we've offered to
discuss this further we've had some
engagement off the back of that
slide please
um so finally I just wanted to touch on
um kind of the Crux of the the recent
Parish Council response which highlights
the concern over how should the fence be
removed acoustic levels will be
maintained in line with the who
recommended level set in the current
planning conditions now Stratford's
already approved a noise strategy
outline stage and which were in the
process of amending and implementing and
the orange and purple phases just shown
on the screen there with the red area
um
shows that there will be a need for an
acoustic mitigation strategy to be
provided at Reserve matters stage and
again that's for Stratford to approve
and they'll then have to implement that
in accordance with the approved details
to comply with that condition now my
understanding of the response is that um
the parishes are seeking for structure
to assure that post-construction monitor
is monitoring is required for new
um homes and noting that the Stratford
enforcement policy is a discretionary
service
um the responses urges members to
consider how this requirement could be
mandated so we think it's fantastic that
the care and attention is being paid at
this stage to to what could arise off
the back of this but
in planning terms this isn't an
appropriate planning application to
attach a condition of this kind to this
program is for green infrastructure the
noise burned attenuation basins it's not
for dwellings it's something that could
be looked at as part of the future
Reserve matters applications when they
submit future noise reports which will
require noise monitoring once the bond
has been constructed in order to
demonstrate that they're complying with
the original condition
um
so just off the back of that
um when we submitted the application it
received a lot of Challenge from
Stratford and we've worked with
Stratford to
um demonstrate that what we are
proposing is sensible and we acknowledge
that whilst there's no planning weight
that could be attached to it the
acoustic fences maintenance and eventual
replacement will need to be funded by
Future residents at upper light horn and
so in bringing this site forward and
we'll continue to work with everyone and
the parish councils to ensure we provide
a positive contribution to this new
settlement and we fully acknowledge the
concerns and concerns that have been
raised and we think there's appropriate
mechanisms are set out in the office of
Rapport to ensure that these future
residents won't be caught by
unacceptable noise levels and so that we
trust that members of the committee can
support the officer's recommendation
thank you thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for our
speaker councilor Parry please
thank you and good evening
um on the Landscaping side on the bond
can you advise
um how mature will the planting and the
trees be
um because so many developers put little
spindly things on the on the buns and
the
you know the sidelines to motorways
um so I'd like to have some more
information on the maturity of the trees
how old they will be yep so because of
the way the Bund is constructed we can't
put fully mature trees on straight away
the reason being that the topsoil that
gets put on top of the Buns needs to be
made stable and a lot of that occurs
through new planting and providing their
Roots which anchors
um the topsoil down and stops the rain
from just washing away the soil now
there is a planning condition on the
original outline consent which requires
us to replant any failing planting
within five years and the rush the
rationale for that is that when you do
this Motorway planting a lot of it does
fail and they have to go back and replan
so in terms of maturity they would be
small species that get put in in the
first instance and we do have that all
specified out as part of our Reserve
matters approval that's already in place
but we wouldn't be able to put ritual
trees because it's just not from a an
engineering point of view it wouldn't be
appropriate for us to put that in so how
how long would these trees take to grow
to their maturity uh three to five years
and we have a view to implement the fall
planting um in the next planting season
so from next November onwards and the
point of that really is that we
acknowledge that the houses are going to
cover a couple two to three years later
but it gives the planting a chance to
mature in that interim time
anyone else
no Mr stanblam thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
right we have no more speakers on this
item so let's move to points for
clarification for the officers
um I'm going to kick us off uh this time
if I may
um we've heard from both uh Parish
Council Representatives
um they were seeking to mandate uh have
a condition that mandates testing am I
writing thinking that we can't add a new
condition to a planning application
that's already been approved and has now
been sought to be varied
yes
um the difficulty with adding conditions
which um in this case is that the
reserve matters application deals with
green infrastructure and nothing else so
you can't place a condition which
relates to the housing Parcels because
this isn't part of the housing parcels
a condition on the future housing
Parcels might be possible but not via
this particular Reserve matters
application lovely thank you very much
um any anyone else councilor Parry
please thank you chair
um
Tony I just wonder whether you've got
any information as when the noise
um the the noise survey was undertaken
in terms of the weather conditions at
the time because I do think it's really
relevant
um in terms of when and we and I
appreciate we have an are in one of our
environmental health officers with us
um there is quite a differential in
noise
projection
During certain different weather
conditions and certainly when it's it's
raining
um
the noises is
Amplified considerably I would I would
like to know
I think it's really important to know
when the the type of inclement
conditions
during when the testing for for this
Bond was carried out
the weather conditions would have been
recorded in the noise reports that were
submitted I can't recall what what those
reports say but they will take that into
consideration I was over the Ben can
comments on weather conditions and noise
levels
um I can't recall what the weather
conditions were but what I can say is
that the report that was submitted with
this sought to do verification
monitoring of the original
um monitoring that was done with the
outline application and came up with
very similar results so it shows that
they are consistent
um across the two monitoring periods so
although I can't really show you about
what the what the conditions are doing
at the time there is at least
consistency in the monitoring that's
been undertaken
any other points of clarification
Council Curtis
so just picking up on that point perhaps
this is something because I think cancer
probably has a very good point about the
difference in noise levels between dry
warm still weather and very windy wet
weather perhaps that is something that
the committee
ought to have in front of them when we
are given noise levels in future we
ought to know what condition what
weather conditions there were at the
time but something for future references
by Major yeah I think that's something
to take offline rather than here
um anyone else have any points of
clarification
one of the reasons why this was deferred
was because we wanted to bring in eha
member to us to to detail
um what is considered significant in
terms of noise and what isn't
um I know no one's asked that so I will
ask it then if you would please
uh thank you chair well I I guess in the
um strictest sense uh significant
impacts would be and impacts that would
result in a exceedance of World Health
Organization or British standard uh
guideline levels
um in terms of significant increase in
noise which is slightly different
we're looking at how much the fence
would result in a a an increase in in
noise levels
and for a 3 DB increase we would not
expect someone to be able to perceive a
difference in the sound level simply
because of the way the the human ear
detects noise
and it's it's accuracy anything below
sort of 3db you wouldn't be able to
detect the difference between three and
about 4.9 is a low you would perceive a
difference but it'd be a low perception
and anything above five decibels we
would say that was a significant
increase in noise because of the way the
the human ear detects the noise
um so therefore looking at the
reports that were submitted to us and we
did robustly challenge the applicant
through the process
um we were comfortable that the results
as they were presented
um showed that there was not likely to
be a significant increase in noise
um and in terms of significant impacts
of that noise that would depend upon the
reserve matters in their final design to
determine what the facade mitigation
should be and what the mitigation to
achieve acceptable levels would be
outside ultimately
thank you Ben just to um just follow up
on that just so I'm clear uh the
difference that this the fence that is
being proposed to be removed would make
the noise you consider to be less than
three decibels is that correct
that's correct yes it's between naught
and 2.4 2.4 being the most severely uh
impacted
um property that's uh presented that's
lovely thank you very much councilor
Adam please thanks um maybe more of a
contextual question relating to what I
think
um
uh the chairman asked first
um with regards to potential conditions
being put on further Reserve matters
applications that I think we're already
considering or will be considering for
these presumably any outcome from those
would only be able to be implemented
within their own Red Line boundaries so
at that point if it were found that
further noise reduction measures were
required they couldn't then
retrospectively be applied to this area
so it would only be isolated is that
right
I just just like I said it's more
contextual just so I know exactly how
how the limits of the conditions work
for for this and future applications
around it
the way things currently stand is that
the outline permission has condition 30
which requires each phase of the housing
developments to submit a noise reduction
scheme that will be considered by the
environmental health officers it will
put it will ratify the the measurements
of the noise it will put forward the
mitigation measures that are required
that in tandem with the layout and the
design of the the parcel of the housing
will then be able to see what measures
are needed for example which units would
need the glazing or the mechanical
ventilation or trickle vents which has
plots would require fencing Ram to get
the gardens for example acoustic fencing
and which dwellings were orientated
Gable end on all frontend on so they
offer protection to to the rest of the
site so those things would be seen in
the realm the noise reduction reports
and the layouts and the detailing
environmental health Team would be able
to look at that and then determine
whether or not that was going to be
acceptable if they felt it wasn't then
they've got the right to to raise an
objection to it okay so just just like
follow up on that would that potentially
be able to then be affected or responded
to through the soft Landscaping
uh Reserve matters permission
if a reserve Master scheme that was
submitted was unacceptable because of
noise implications it would either be
refused orbit asked for amendments to
the scheme to the layout or to the
mitigation measures
the council Parry please
thank you I may maybe I might have
misunderstood the applicant when he
referred to the if if residents moved in
and then uh raised
um concerns with enforcement that
um any in further Improvement to
acoustic would would be down to the
residents
um I'm just wondering is there any is
there any
um way that part of a section 106
agreement could could reflect that the
actual applicants
if if additional noise prevention was
required then that would be down to the
applicants to produce not residents
because obviously the plots adjacent to
the motorway
um are not going to they're going to be
less expensive
from a purchaser point of view than
those
more towards the Parish of of upper
light horn and I'm just concerned that
people move in to small houses perhaps
by the motorway
and then because the of the noise
situation are not are not in a position
to pay for additional Acoustics if
that's required
it's a difficult one because with that I
mean we're speculating on what might be
the causes of the noise it could be a
defect in the bond itself in which case
it would probably be down to the
management company to rectify that issue
if it was a defects in the glazing or
the ventilation of the particular
property then it would be down to the
house bill to rectify that on the basis
that they're solid defective house to
the to the um the house owner other than
that we've kind of speculating about
what might be the cause what might be
the duration what might be the harm
whether or not it's over the limits
until all of the facts alone is pure
speculation really but that would be
generally the the outcome gee if I may
just follow on from that and this might
help give cancer Parry a bit of comfort
the um the condition I think condition
30 requires us uh the is it prior to
occupations that the sound levels are
met or the part of the sound levels
Reserve matters so we're going to be
there's going to be a requirement and
full assessment of the sound at the uh
the properties windows for example
um meeting who standards at that stage
and we won't be approving Reserve
matters until those conditions are met
is that right
not entirely condition 30 requires it
sets down limits on noise levels within
garden areas and within habitable rooms
within the dwellings
and that those levels stay with every
development parcel and every every phase
of the development
if someone moves in and thinks that
there's an issue with the noise levels
then it would be investigated
investigated by the enforcement team
potentially with the input of the
environmental health team as well as I
say we're speculating about what the
cause of that noise might be or whether
or not it's above level or something
whether it's significantly above or not
that's helpful actually thank you casa
Mills please
thanks Mr chairman I'm just trying to
get clear on my mind going back to the
trees
um are we saying that the trees are
helping to
um
stop the noise you know or are we saying
that planting the trees will help the
noise levels
no as I understand matters planting
makes very little difference
yes it's not part of the calculator the
modeling the planting is not part of the
modeling for the noise assessment no
right okay
okay any more questions before we move
into debates no let's move into debates
who would like to kick us off
anyone councilor Parry sort of twitching
do you want to go first
I might as well
um
I don't
I I totally understand where the the two
Parish councils are coming from
um but at the end of the day I'm not a
noise expert none of us around the
tables are noise experts apart from our
well committee members aren't noise
experts
um and therefore I feel we have to go
with the officer's recommendation
because
um
I'm not an expert and I I understand the
concerns I also understand that at this
particular Junction of this application
because we're waiting for Reserve
matters of the housing to come forward
we cannot
um
make additional conditions on this but
what I would like to see would be some
note that certainly the noise aspects
are fully investigated at the reserve
matters and that that perhaps some
further investigation is done
um when when conditions are wet on the
motorway and windy as well as in dry
conditions and on that basis I'm
prepared to propose Grant
thank you very much cancer Parry um I
I'm going to dive in here if you don't
mind and second that I agree with that
everything absolutely everything you've
said
um what does give me Comfort is knowing
that uh we have a condition that
requires all the noise be assessed
before the reserve matters
um given the defense provides at its
peak 2.4 decibels of protection which
we've also heard is below the three
decibels that is not perceptible by a
human ear
um I'm I'm very comfortable to go ahead
with this I formed my second cancel Adam
please beat me to it chair
Council Curtis do you stick a fin out
cancer Mills yeah somebody just made a
comments Mr chairman
um if we'd had this fence in the first
place we wouldn't be here
um so that's what I have to say we
should have had the fence in the first
place we wouldn't be here discussing
um noise levels thank you
I think we're actually trying to remove
the fence rather than add it in so but I
take your point
um if no one else has got anything that
they want to add to the debate we'll
move to a vote could I please have a
show so the proposal is to Grant uh
application 2201385 very inline with the
officer's recommendation with the
additional note
um which I can see has been written down
so I won't I won't bore you with the
details of it
um Cloud show of hands in favor of
granting
uh
nine and against
and abstentions one in that case
Community resolves to Grant application
2201385 very
okay let's move on to our next item of
the evening which is application
reference
2201870 ful this is cattle yard
westmeads Farm in Butler's Marston our
presenting officer is once again Tony
Horton and as soon as Tony's ready he
will begin I have no doubt
thank you chairman apologies for the
delay so
the application context plan there shows
the application site located Southwest
of the village of Butler's Marston of
the piloton road marked by the black
circle and
north
east of politenhursty
application sites edged red
comprises a parcel of agricultural land
located south of the piloton road the
site Falls within open Countryside is
located in a relatively isolated rural
location
currently on site there is a Dutch barn
and a brick Barn
show you a photograph of those
there's the brick barn and then the
Dutch metal Barn there
the
um the brick Barn has got uh already got
planning approval for a clap what's
called a class queue conversion to a
dwelling
and the
the Dutch Barn would be taken down in
that class queue permission
another photograph of the brick Barn
that's got approval for the class Q
residential conversion
show the
proposed site plan so we can see there's
an existing access here which will be
retained and modified to go into the
site the site of the steel frame Dutch
Barn here will be used for parking and
hard standing
the site for the brick Barn here will be
used for a two-story four-bed dwelling
the entire site is proposed to be
domestic cartilage
there's no indication that any trees
will be removed through the application
process
I'll show you the elevations of The
Proposal
so as I say it's a four bedroom
two-story house
traditional materials local Stone and
play Clyde plain clay tiled roof and
Timber windows
do have the floor plans to show if
members want to see them
now as I referred to previously the
class Q approval that's already on site
this is a legitimate fallback position
that the council needs to consider
in weighing up the
um the proposals
a consideration of the difference
between this that could be built and the
current proposals needs to be taken and
in the offices of reports for the
reasons that I'll go into shortly it
concludes that this class queue is
preferable to the current proposals
I'll now show you a couple of slides
which show some comparisons
so
first off in relation to the site-aged
red the domestic cartilage on the
approved class queue
on the left hand side here excluding the
building footprint the cartilage area of
the property that's the line edged red
there is about 170 square meters
on the right hand side the current
application before members this evening
you can see the extent of the cartilage
minus the the building footprint is 1900
square meters so the concern there from
officers is an urbanization of the open
Countryside a change of use from what is
agricultural land to domestic garden
areas and domestic paraphernalia
and then secondly the other comparison
that's been made
is of the uh the visual impact
particularly in terms of the Heights on
the left hand side the approved class Q
reaches approximately 5.4 meters to the
ridge
and on the right hand side the proposal
before us this evening
reaches about 9.5 meters to the Ridge
and so the officer conclusion is that
this is far more intrusive to in the
character of the landscape and the
general area in what is the most
isolated rural location
the Germany is for those two reasons
um mainly that officer's recommendation
is that the proposal before us is not
preferable to the fallback position of
the class queue and therefore the
development is unacceptable in principle
thank you
Tony thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item
who's councilor Simon Corp who is
Chairman of Butler's masterton Parish
Council I hope I pronounce your surname
correctly perfect
marvelous so um councilor I'm sure
you're aware you'll have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up otherwise when you're
ready press the button and the floor is
yours
uh good evening everybody uh I'm
speaking this evening on behalf of
balance Marston Parish Council in
support of this planning application
there has been unanimous support from
the parish council for this application
and there is consensus opinion from all
the residents that we have spoken to
and from the many comments submitted to
the eve hunting system
the dwelling will be less than 400
meters from the main village area so
it's more in keeping with the village
than it is within a rural environment
the parish council feel the scheme would
be far more in keeping with the
surrounding
and the Aesthetics of the village than
the existing structure and the class Q
consent
as the barn is in such a close proximity
to the road it is imposing as you enter
an exit Village its presence is further
accessible by the current dilapidated
state
and would further so by the existing
planning proposal using modern materials
many of the buildings in the village
date back to the 1800s
the pro proposed plans outline materials
using local Stone
and it's far more in keeping with the
parish houses compared to the modern
Barn conversion that is proposed in the
class Cube planning the proposed
materials in this application would be
more sympathetic to the local area
the existing Q class plans include
significant amounts of glass and
cladding
there are no similar buildings in the
village or the parish this would be in
huge contrast to and would look far more
industrial than any other building along
that road and not in keeping with the
local area
we hope
that the committee today will consider
all that we put forward the village and
the parish has a very strong Community
spirit and we feel that this proposed
dwelling would be more in keeping with
the rest of the area so we hope you'll
consider this application for its merits
and will bring to the Village the
positive impact it will have on the
community and The Wider Street Scene
thank you so cool thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our counselor
no in that case thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening we
will call our next speaker who is James
Hodgkins welcome back
James I'm sure you're well versed in
this it's three minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're sat comfortable
and ready press the button and the floor
is yours
members thank you for your time this
evening and providing me with an
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
applicant Mr Sheamus Henderson my name
is James Hodgkins and I'm here to ask
you to support this application in
accordance with the wishes of the parish
council and the local community
as you've heard the application seeks
permission for the demolition of the
Redundant Barns and the construction of
a new self-built home
my way background planning permissions
previously previously been granted for
the conversion of one of the bonds to
create a three-bedroom dwelling the
residential use of the site has
therefore been firmly established and
considered acceptable
as the permission remains extant until
May 2025 there is a significant fallback
position this is an important material
consideration
indeed the print in principle terms
officers do not consider there to be a
material difference between the proposed
dwelling and the approved scheme the key
matters of consideration therefore
relate to design appearance and the
impact of The Proposal on the side and
surroundings
from the outset I'd highlight the
applicant's primary aim is to deliver
high quality traditional dwelling that
is more befitting of the carriage
Butler's Marston than the consented
scheme
the design has been carefully considered
to be sympathetic to the local
vernacular and built typology
the consented conversion has modern
appearance and introduces contemporary
materials including a metal roof lots of
cladding and large expanses of glazing
this is not reflective of the appearance
of the village to the country the
proposed Walling will be finished in
Natural Stone play with tiles will have
painted Timber windows and doors in
short it is far more appropriate for
locality and represents a significant
improvement over and above the extant
permission
proposal also integrates the host of
renewable energy measures built fabric
efficiency improvements
whilst while cities acknowledge that the
Heiser dwelling has increased this is
necessitated by the ambition to deliver
a farm farmhouse style home we'd also
highlight that the footprint of the
building has actually been reduced to
minimize the Quantum of build
development on site a further benefit
includes the removal of the Dutch Barn
which isn't the case for the class Q
scheme which would remain prominent and
imposing future
with regards the officer's comments and
respect to domestication we'd highlight
that the site could be strictly
controlled through the removal of
permitted development rights and the
front of the site will continue to be
landscaped
importantly the proposed development is
welcomed by the local community and has
received resounding support from local
residents in the parish council
lastly I'd like to highlight that there
is a shortfall and supply of 81
self-built plots across the district the
proposals make an important contribution
to addressing this need
the Southfield nature of the proposal is
a material consideration and therefore
should be afforded significant weight 30
seconds overall the application will
deliver an attractive self-build home
that reflects the Royal character of the
site and typology of Butler's Marston it
is a significant improvement over the
consented scheme as attractive support
from the local community in this regard
well we respect for our support
James thank you very much indeed members
do we have any questions for our agents
please
no in that case thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
we have no more speakers on this item so
uh do we have any points clarification
for our officers
no accounts Curtis
thank you
um
the one of the comments in the report
was the
um that this second application could
lead to a sort of increased urbanization
but can can you just confirm that I
understand there was no intention to
remove any of the trees
around the property
yes according to the the layout there
the trees are not shown as being failed
but that doesn't mean to say from
officer's point of view if that became
Garden area then there are certain
permitted rights for that to to have uh
structures on like trampolines Wendy
houses washing lines things like that
which would start to urbanize and
encroach into what is currently
agricultural land
would would a TPO be possible as a
condition on this well we remind you to
approve
but it's not in a Conservation Area
um I'm not I don't think any of the
trees have got outstanding immunity
value
um which would warrant a tree
preservation or the
they are shown as being retained
um
but that's all I could say at this stage
if I may follow up on that if we were if
if we were money to approve would a
group TPO on the basis that we want to
protect uh the area against urbanization
be a suitable
phraseology I suppose a suitable
condition
um
this was permitted a condition could be
placed on that approval of the retention
of the scheme to retain and manage the
trees in for the long term could be put
forward so as a condition that would
result in the need to have a presented
scheme from the applicant and how
they're going to maintain the trades is
that is that what you said
it could be a scheme for approval
showing which trees are to be retained
and the long-term management of those
um for approval okay that's helpful
thank you Council Harvey
um
I couldn't see in the officers report
any mentioned of built period boundary
and I presume that is because Butler's
Marsden is small so small it doesn't
have the bill to variant boundary a
could I have confirmation that's correct
and if that is correct would I be
writing saying that this site does well
and truly lie in open Countryside
yes the slide there shows that the the
application site is not within the
confines or on the edge of any
settlement it's around about 400 meters
from Butler's Marston I don't know if
Butler's master has got a defined
Village envelope
um but if it did have it certainly
wouldn't extend as far as the
application side so it is open isolate
cancer Curtis thank you and to just go
back to the sort of urbanization can you
clarify the diff what the difference in
the garden area would be with the extent
class queue and the revised so would the
class Q
exclude that area as Garden
I'll just sort of slightly curious to
understand how that would work
this is the approved class queue site
Edge red so it's only the building and
the area within that line edged red
that's got the approval to be used
as opposed to the application site
application
before you this evening which is the
whole of the site edged red would become
effectively domestic Garden
so so what would happen
to
sorry would is that land
that whole plot would it be is it owned
by the class Q applicant
and it would there then be a condition
if the class Q went to prevent it being
used as Garden would it have to be
retained as agricultural land
as things currently stand
that whole plot is agricultural land the
classic queue
the the barn the brick Barn would become
a domestic dwelling the area around it
within that line-edged red would become
domestic cartilage the remainder of that
and the the other Barn would stay in
agricultural use
it could still be in the ownership of
the class queue occupiers but they
wouldn't be able to use it for anything
other than agricultural if they did
change the use then that would be open
to potential enforcement
Castle Mills
so effective they couldn't have you know
you mentioned swings and trampolines so
they couldn't have that on that um that
land then well that's their
not unless they were very small no
very small in terms of fitting in within
that Redline cartilage if they wanted
anything it fits within there
okay any more questions counts for
Hunter seraphin yeah
um is the new property that's proposed
is the footprint greater than the
existing Barn
thank you
just zoom in to this area
what happened there
apologies
so the red dashed line is the outline of
the current brick Barn
and so the dwelling that goes on that
site is slightly it's slightly overlap
it goes further than the footprint of
the barn in this direction but not as
far in that direction
okay thank you
I think the footprint of the barn is
about 168 square meters the footprint of
the house is 146 square meters but
obviously the house has got more than
one story so in total floor area
the barn because it has a mezzanine
floor put into it with a class queue
that has 200 square meters the house
would have 292 square meters
okay thank you
okay any other questions for me today no
let's dive into debate who's going to
kick us off counselor Dixon please
thank you chairman
uh I heard people describe the proposed
property as more of a farmhouse
and that they didn't like the idea that
it would be cladding on the
existing Barn as a queue because they
thought that was alien to the Village
I however have the alternative opinion
that this is an isolated
Barn quarter miles from the village
and cladding is probably more akin to an
agricultural building being converted
I don't like the height that is being
proposed here I don't like the extent of
the domestic Garden being proposed that
I am going to propose the officer's
recommendation of reviews
thank you very much Council Dixon
Council Mills please yes thank you Jim
yeah I mean just just looking at the two
um
if it was me I'd you know if I'm going
to buy something I'd go for the house I
mean it does fit in with the um the
village and we're just outside the
village it was Natural Stone that's
natural stone looking at the um
uh the proposed drawings of the class
queue it's it's awful I mean to look at
that from the road I think it's Dreadful
so Mr chairman I will go against
officer's recommendation I much prefer
the um the stone building thank you just
so I can confirm are you proposing Grant
and if you are we'll come back to you
for your reasons shortly if you are
proposing Grant thank you very much
Council Adam please
thank you chair
um I think I'm gonna go along with
councilor Dixon on this one I do agree
about the size the cartilage and a
quarter of a mile outside the village
isn't really in the village so I'm happy
to second that proposal thank you very
much indeed anyone else councilor Crump
just very briefly to add on to council
Adam's Point um yeah it's out and out in
the countryside it doesn't meet our
party has turned for a permanent
development for occupation by a rural
Walker worker even and the design and
quality of the drilling is an
exceptional in my opinion so it's
definitely against on policy I can
understand why it's been brought in this
way but I won't be supporting this and
we'll go with the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
councilor Parry please
well I'm someone that actually knows
Mark Butler's Marston really really well
um obviously if this proposal was in
front of us where we didn't have a class
queue
um permission in place
it would just be thrown out altogether
because it is
out in the country it it it it it it is
not distinctive enough to become a
um an Innovative type of dwelling
however it does reflect I would say
probably in terms of its style a good 90
95 of other properties that are in
Butler's Marston and the bomb is very
alien to what is currently in Butler's
Marston so I have great sympathy with
um
the parish council I also note we have
11 letters of support and for those of
you who haven't been to Butler's
masterton it's a very small little
Hamlet and there aren't many other
people there are there isn't a huge
number of people that actually live in
Butler's Marston so I have every
sympathy it's rare that we have
um Parish councils come forward with
support and other villagers we don't
live in Butler's Marston and I I I I can
totally understand why they feel the
bomb is out of context
um and for someone who has visited has
driven past the site that knows Butler's
mastered really well
I'm going to Second councilor Mills
proposal to Grant on the basis that the
new proposal in front of us is more is
is more
sympathetic into the design and the
character of The Village
okay Curtis please
thank you completely agree with
everything that I suppose just been
saying and I think you know we do in
this committee I think we it is very
very important that we do listen to
local views listen to local parishes and
take their views into account
um it is separate from the village but
it does tie in far more with the village
vernacular than the class queue
um
and this application also does see the
removal of the Dutch Barn which is not a
thing of great Beauty as it currently
stands and certainly if we were able to
condition in some respect the retention
of the trees on site I would be voting
against the officer's recommendation on
this
thank you Council Harvey
I will be supporting the the officer's
recommendation
um
this is we to counter Council Perry's
point we are here to apply the council's
agreed policies across the district
without fear or favor
but this is a house a domestic
urbanizing house that's proposed in the
open Countryside and as councilor said
Council Paris said if this had been put
forward with that class Q
consent being present this would be
kicked out it would it would be refused
um there is Good Grounds to argue that
the class queue is preferable in in this
particular instance in this particular
location
we are here to adhere to
as10 in particular protecting the open
Countryside this house
whichever class Cube or the proposed
house is nowhere near the village it's
not in the village it is in open
Countryside and I think it's our duty to
enforce and respect the policies I will
be supporting the officer's
recommendation thank you very much
anyone else before I Chuck my thoughts
in
Council angel
yeah
um
the thing that bothers me is the actual
height and scale of the new building
if the roof level was to be dropped
um it wouldn't look so imposing
um
the barn on the left
doesn't look very attractive
but I'm
a bit uncomfortable with him thank you
thank you last chance for the last
people before I go in right I'm going in
okay so
um cancer Curtis to respond to what you
said before about how important it is
that we listen to the uh the thoughts of
the parish councils and the residents
absolutely agree couldn't agree more we
should do but we should also uh pay the
same level possibly more uh attention to
as Council Harvey said our policies and
National policies
um so I'm taking that as a starting
point uh it's Council Mills point about
the uh the house itself being much more
and cancer parody I think being much
more keeping with um Butler's Marston
couldn't agree more yeah it is but it's
not in Butler's Marston it's almost half
a kilometer outside in the open
Countryside would I expect to see a
relative new build of that style in the
open Countryside no would I expect to
see a class Q style conversion
absolutely I would expect to see that in
this location do I like that class queue
application no but that's subjective
someone might I'm sure someone will
otherwise they wouldn't have designed it
in the way that they have so it then
falls down to is the proposed more
harmful than what has already been
approved and as we've already heard I
mean 9.5 meters in height
um uh I think a reduction in floor space
of about 30 meters the hard standing at
the front for the gravel driveway in the
parking of cars and intensification on
the site urbanization is absolutely a
word I would use so I am going to be
going with the officer recommendation
and refusing
um unless anyone else has anything they
want to say let's go to a vote no one's
gonna say let's move to a vote then so
um The Proposal is to refuse in line
with the officer recommendation proposed
by cancer Dixon seconded by cancer Eden
uh could have a show thanks for those in
favor refusal please
seven and those against
do and abstentions one so committee
therefore resolves two refuse
application twenty two zero one eight
seven zero ful that's cathyard
westmead's Farm in Butler's Marston
marvelous let's move on to our next item
and we are gonna have a little bit of a
shuffle of our offices so forgive me
while we have a brief moment of that but
our presenting officer of this next item
is Victoria Kempton the application
reference is
2202102 ful garages in Wilm cut
as soon as Victoria is settled and
comfortable I have no doubt she will
begin
good evening and thank you chair
so the application site is located in
the village of wilmcote and is
identified by the black dot on the map
the site is outlined in Black which has
22 lock-up garages and is positioned in
two rows the site is located in the
green belt as well
in terms of the context residential
homes lied to the north east and west of
the site and there's also an open
Countryside beyond the South
there's a public right of way as
highlighted in green to the South
there's also a private private
right-of-way which intersects the
western edge of the site
permission is sought to demolish the
garages in place of three dwellings and
Associated development The Proposal
includes the addition of a pair of
semi-detached homes are seen at plots
one and two and a detached house has
seen at plot three this property would
also have a detached garage which would
be cited forward of the front elevation
this slide shows the design of the
proposed pair of semi-detached homes
which would have two bedrooms each the
design is simple in form with solar
panels on the rear renovation the
materials would be facing brick plain
concrete roof tiles white upvc windows
and black faces and rainwater Goods
so this slide shows a profession
proposed attached home at plot 3.
you can see it's got a very very similar
designers to the proposed character of
plots one and two
these are the elevations of the proposed
garage
the the two Street Scene plans below
show how the development would relate to
the neighboring properties which are
shown in Gray the ground level of the
site is slightly higher than the
neighboring property at number 27 and as
a result the homes would have a higher
Ridge height by approximately 400
millimeters however the plan to the
right shows that the development would
have would be approximately 200
millimeters lower
these site photos illustrate the
existing arrangement of the garages
which would open into a four core area
the lockups have confirmed to be
available to let for dry storage as
they're unsuitable for vehicles
photo number three shows the public
right-of-way which runs behind the
garages and you can just see that the
back of the garage is there
so this slide shows the areas context
and you can see how the opening of the
site relates to the area in photo number
one
and yeah the photos on the right show
the level of on-street car parking in
glaive Estates at the time at the time
of my site visit on a Friday afternoon
you can see that there were a number of
cars to the west of the site with some
cars on the pavement although there was
less on-street car parking to the north
of the site ocean photo number three
the application is recommended for
approval subject to the conditions and
reasons outlined in the offices report
and this concludes my presentation the
big story thank you very much indeed
let's call our first speaker on this
item is councilor Carl McMillan
good evening councilor
thank you for your patience
um as with everyone else you'll have
three minutes I'll give you 30 second
warning whenever you're ready feel free
to start that evening I'm ready to
represent the residents and the
councilors myself as a resident used to
live in Glebe estate
um
we don't disapprove to the building of
houses and demolishment of the garages
what we disapprove of is the fact that
nobody has paid any attention to ongoing
parking issues in glebeaver state
uh the land at the front of caliber
state is also owned by orbit as who own
the garages who want to knock them down
and build houses
currently residents are having to park
on the pavement the photographed uh
Vicky showed was taken on a Friday
afternoon when most people are probably
at work which have probably done been
taken on a Friday evening when literally
all the way up that pavement
because our parts people cannot walk
under NDP wp2 states that
when when that identified adverse
traffic impacts arising from this
proposal we don't think these have been
here to
um some of the residents have written in
objection to the parking facilities and
of our saw bits if I could buy some of
the land so that they can actually Park
their cars in their Road
we can have three more houses with at
least six more cars
and hunting visitors and they're just
going to met their parking cities even
worse in that road
we're not against the houses the South
we're just against the lack of parking
and the lack of being listened to by all
bit of the parking facility in that in
that road
thank you very much councilor members do
we have any questions for our councilor
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman
um I'm asking you for local information
and knowledge there you I think you
mentioned that you used to live on the
Cleveland State
one of the comments we've got on our
page 48 I'll read it too recommended
pre-commencement conditions for a public
footpath creation agreement for the
right-of-way between Glebe estate and
the footpath and the orbits are made a
map reflecting the right away going
through the site
um now we've seen where the public
broadcast is which is along the canal is
there access from the estate through the
garages at the present time which the
residents regularly use yes
um if you go back to the
site plan so from on the top left
uh as I used to actually live at the top
of the road so and I used to walk my
dogs daily down the road
straight through the garages straight
out the back and then onto the footpath
because if you go left where the access
is you might get run over a tractor and
then the public foot path is runs down
the back which runs from the top of the
village all the way down to the bottom
of the village thank you so there
actually is a I'm not sure what the
legality of having a right way in
prepared Duty going across the garages
because I've been there 28 years and
I've walked it daily thank you we will
we'll ask the officers that very thing
uh did I see a finger up go up the side
Council Mills
um
the garage at the moment are the are
they in use at all I believe some of
them are in use but they are
and to be fair they've been refurbished
four years ago but they've been
neglected because they won't rent them
out because I want to knock them down
and are the residents using
um that site to put their cards on at
the moment to get them off the road yeah
thank you
questions members
no in that case councilor thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening
so we go to our next speaker on this
item is counselor Ian shenton good
evening councilor shenton
you're very smart and Dapper as usual
councilor shenton you know the drill
five minutes 30 second warning whenever
you're ready and press the button I will
start the timer the floor is yours
thank you very much thank you very much
um thank you everybody good evening to
everyone first slide please if we could
just go to the first slide
okay so it's a not very good shot list
but we'll we'll move on to the second
slide and we're going to move through
through these slides very very quickly
the parking issues uh that we that uh
Carla's as a alluded to are similar to
the application that you looked at on
the 12th of October 22 travelo 720
presenting that time by councilor Mills
a number of councilors at that meeting
recognized and stated that parking
issues on orbit owned land uh were are
actually being ignored by orbit can we
move on to the next slide please
the planner hopefully acknowledges that
there was a vehicle parked there on the
day of a report and you can see on this
slide in actual fact
um this was taken on the morning
uh one morning last week and you can see
the network actual fact just after nine
o'clock there's significantly more
Vehicles there parked on both sides the
vehicles on the left are passed on the
pavement
so that the PC you know only too well as
I do how bad the parking is it's the
PC's judgment that you should rely on on
this many of the cars that you see in
this slide and if we move on to the next
slide as well please
uh I'll carry on while that's I parked
on the pavement so elderly vulnerable
children and adults those with mobility
issues are forced onto the road and have
to crisscross the road near a 90 degree
Bend
the police have been informed but the
police obviously the Thin Line Thin Blue
Line is too thin to come and deal with
these production parking issues orbit
don't want to know about them Vehicles
parked unauthorized within the garage
area which at least helps to alleviate
the issues that we Face elsewhere along
the street highways are only concerned
in their report with the area in the red
line and the approach road to the side
healthfully at the last meeting
councilor Rock pointed the committee to
cs9 uh our cancer pair together
appointed the committee all said to
cs-26 but cs9 is the one I'll rely on
the planning manager and the chair
stated the members could attach as much
weight to the parking issue as they
wished at that time so the issue of
having to consider the greater Blue Line
area and parking is in effect
established and that's important
an argument thrown up might be that the
parking would be displaced whether we
put the houses on the site or not and
that may be correct but that also
ignores the fact that orbits are
responsible to the residents within the
red and blue line areas and therefore
parking issues are a material
consideration
additionally as the principle of parking
issues being considered was established
and confirmed at the committee the NDP
then starts to take Primacy on what and
where development should take place and
under what circumstances
the NDP vision statement stays in its
third objective it will manage future
housing growth and policy wp-9b and E
come into play along with WP 10 and
wp-12 and wp-12 states that where there
are identified adverse traffic impacts
arising from the proposed development
the applicant will be required to and
identify and incorporate measures to
deal with these impacts clear and
unambiguous
any loss of the parking in this area is
a reduction in parking and should be
resisted the parish council and its
residents voted for the NDP and SDC and
the inspectors approved it so therefore
it is valid sits on top of the course
strategy there's little doubt in the
minds of the parish council that the
development will have impacts whether
the existing garage is being used for
parking is authorized or unauthorized
the reality is that there are possibly
many vehicles using the site when
residents return home from work and the
school run Etc so the reduction in
parking will be more than that one
vehicle that the planner observed on
that day
the flywheel quite rightly be expressed
in an opinion taking into account the
limited view that highways would have
had highways have not been asked to
comment on The Wider area only the
approach Road and development itself the
road is not wide enough to support the
number of residents with cars and it's
just debatable whether a fire engine or
refuse truck which measures roughly 2.3
to 2.9 meters would be able to reach
either a fire or bins further down the
road 30 seconds safety is possible
possibly being compromised
to reiterate the principle of looking at
the wider aerial the area has been
established cs9 and 26 appear to support
that view and the NDP of WP 9 10 and 12
are there therefore come into play and I
would ask you to reject this application
or refuse this application in its
current form due to the impacts of
parking on The Wider area and on the
grounds the potential impacts of parking
on The Wider area are unacceptable
thank you
you are you're two seconds over but I
shall allow it
um members do we have any questions for
councilor Shannon please Council Adam
thanks uh thank you councilor um
obviously parking is the main issue that
you seem to raise have you um are you
aware of the parking survey that's been
carried out by
um
a
surveyor that might be able to do that I
know I had a very similar case in my
award and that was what was pursued at
that point
thank you counselor no not aware of any
survey having been carried out at all
um it is it is uh fairly simple to in
actual fact a simple question to the
police would have I would certainly
identify that we've reported the the
issues there many times we've also been
in contact with Orbit on a number of
occasions as soon as as recently as may
this year
um there's there is no doubt that we
have big issues on that road and the uh
it can it can only be work get worse
with the loss of the parking space
authorized or unauthorized
um in that around the garages
anyone else have a question for cancer
seraphim hello
um
are these houses in the near vicinity
are they all orbit houses
all the houses
and within the Blue Line area which goes
as you look at that plan goes to the the
Western to the left of the plan yeah all
those are orbit all the ones to the
north of Atlanta
that they have on they have their own
on-street parking to the left have no
sorry they are off street parking the
ones
there we go if you look at that so you
can see the road coming down there yeah
mostly a lot of those houses coming down
have on the street park off street
parking and the ones and you come around
that bin
um and you've got the garages in the
bottom there and they're all off street
parking so you have a narrow road uh of
roughly about 4.5 meters you have
vehicles uh your average
um your average SUV with about 2.3
liters and you're going to struggle to
get and with cars park on the pavement
blocking uh the pavement altogether
you've got the the prospect of
pedestrians in the road and if we've got
an emergency of getting a mobile
vehicles I can see that I mean one's
parked on the paper and totally
oh if you're not going to ask a question
you're debating and and we're not in
that stage yet we apologize thank you
thank you very much cancer Parry please
thank you good evening Council shinton
can you advise
um has wilmco Parish Council carried out
a recent housing needs survey and if so
is there a need for small affordable
housing in the village
the the uh I'll probably answer this
better in that there is no objection in
principle to the development of that
site
um for housing the the
objection that we're raising is centered
around parking the latest there is I
think in the plan in the report you had
and when the latest housing need survey
was carried out and that hasn't been
carried out within the time I've been a
district councilor
um so it goes back some years
um and as the previous councilor
mentioned you know we're not we don't if
in principle have a problem with this
but the whole property will exacerbate
the issues there and we need the whole
scheme the whole area dealt with as one
not just in isolation like this
Council Retton
thank you chair
um you may have mentioned this in your
speech so I'm ever so sorry if I missed
it have you got a rough idea of how many
cars would be displaced from the garage
area in terms of parking
[Music]
um
I I come down to go down that road if we
go further down that road to as you look
at it on the screen to the left the The
Village Hall is down there and a school
play and a play area around that area
so when I come down there to go to the
parish council meetings I see cars
scattered everywhere on the pavement on
the road up in the garages I I have to
say
I I can be sad at the number of things
but I haven't counted how many vehicles
there on anyone on anyone particularly
sorry I can't help you
any more questions for our Ward member
no in that case cancer sentence
Sanctuary time and contribution this
evening
okay we'll move to points of
clarification for our officers um we did
uh say that I would ask one earlier on
so the foot path and access to I presume
that is being maintained
um and more importantly safely
maintained
um thank you so
as I mentioned earlier there's a there's
a there is a public right-of-way which
goes to the rear of the garages along
here there is also a private
right-of-way which goes along here but I
believe it's previously alluded to an
informal access which went through the
garages out to the back I don't know if
that's that's correct
um but on my site visit there was an
opening in in the Hedge down here but
I'm not aware of any any formal rights
of way which would would allow that okay
so so the uh the formal access which I
think is that little green section
on the left side of the proposed site
plan that's being maintained so people
will still be able to walk through there
and access the public footpath behind is
that correct
that is correct and we do
we do some assumptions to
um limit the construction of
um you go so condition eight the
agricultural access shall not be removed
or modified so that area has been left
clear to to preserve the right of way
down there
lovely thank you very much any other
points clarification Council Harvey
please
um seven Trent so that's an informative
note regarding the position of public
sewers
does that mean to contact them to find
out where it is
yes sorry so I believe that is to
um to ensure that the applicant contacts
seven Trent to inform them regarding the
position of any public sewers that might
be in or around the site
you'll prob you'll notice it's listed
again on on uh 0.4 of the Note 7 Trend
and so as Victoria said it is a an
informative note
in its simplest form cancel Adam please
um I'm all right then in understanding
that these would be built and
effectively run as affordable housing
dwellings by orbit
it's not sold
so they're proposed as Market dwellings
um the two two semi's attached two
bedrooms and the third one being three
bedroom detached one so not affordable
but but Market
foreign
let's move to the base who would like to
go first I'm going to pick someone on
the left-hand side councilor Adam's
going to go first today
yeah thank you um I'm intrigued by this
one because it on the face of it looks
almost identical to one I had in my ward
which
there are some key differences though
which are sort of maybe swaying me
slightly
um
but I think the parking is the situation
that was the issue in ours and it's
clearly the issue here that the parish
council and the board member have which
I completely sympathize with because I
think it's something that
is in well I think it's been an issue in
these types of Estates for a while now
because of the age of when they were
built and and the amount of cars that
we're having and the size of the cars
we're having
um that being said
the
the number of spaces that they are
providing as part of the development
does meet our requirements and that's
normally the thing that I have the main
issue with when it comes to the impact
on neighboring parking immunity
I think there's no real
on so that we can consider here
for the parking problems I think more
broadly outside of this place as a
council we should be putting more
pressure on orbit we should be putting
more pressure on the highways Authority
uh to make these things better I'm not
convinced that this is the place that we
kind of can raise that and with that in
mind I'm sort of inclined to say that
because it meets the parking
requirements as per SPD that I can't see
any otherwise majorly material reasons
to go against it
um broadly speaking I'm happy to to go
along with the officer's recommendation
I'll wait and see what other people say
just to try and get a feel of the room
but that's my uh feeling so far
be bold and commit to it now
councilor Eden
thank you chair
um councilor Adam did actually mention
quite a lot of what I was going to say
um I've seen more or less I think is one
thing that I would say this is
self-sufficient in terms of our policies
providing parking for it
I note that the the ward member and and
the parish councilor are both open to
development on that site which to my
mind is going to displace whatever parks
there anyway whether you build one house
or three
so
I'll be bold and I'll propose that we go
with the officer's recommendation to to
Grant on this one good man thank you
very much uh councilor Parry next please
thank you chair I will be uh going with
the officer's recommendation and it's
always interesting to know when we we
have now a clear development strategy
from orbit don't we
um basically in any village where
they've got current garages we will be
seeing similar developments come forward
and there are no material planning
reasons to refuse this so as far as I'm
concerned and from what I can see so
it'll be a carbon copy like it was in
Kyneton and like other places so
um I'm I'm sympathetic to the parish
council and the residence but it is a
clear development strategy by orbit to
convert all their garage blocks because
we've had it in wellsborn to similar
developments where we have no material
planning reasons to refuse can I just
confirm is that a formal secondary for
councilor Evans proposal
happy to Second thank you very much
indeed uh councilman Mills next please
yes thanks Mr chairman yes it is a a
mirror image of kinds and I mean it's
exactly the same I think
councilor shenton have probably read my
script but it's identical um yeah I
still maintain that orbit have a duty of
care
um to their residents and this certainly
doesn't help it I think they should go
away
and think quite I for all these garages
um um are being sold off which I think
they're intending to do is just creating
misery absolute misery in these Villages
so uh
I can't
go with the office of recommendation
because it is a mirror image of kinds
and I thank you Mr chairman
cancer Curtis please
thank you
um it's unfortunate I don't think that
the fact that there is unauthorized
parking in this area however regrettable
the loss of that unauthorized parking
may be it's really not on material
planning consideration is it
short and sweet anyone else before we go
to a vote no The Proposal is to Grant
Anonymous officer recommendation made by
councilor Ed and seconded by councilor
Parry uh could I please have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting
questions
eight and those against
one and abstentions
one
can we see therefore resolves to Grant
application twenty two zero two one zero
two fuel it's garages at uh well cut
right let's move on to our last and
final item of the evening which is
application 22 zero two three seven zero
fuel T cozy cottage in Ulster our
presentation officer is Orion O'Keefe
Ryan as soon as you're set up ready to
go you can begin
thank you chairman
the application site is denoted by the
time
off onto this
a raised platform
um with the block plan showing the
position of the platform in context the
dwelling
and some
forget it we have Gremlins in our Tech
at the moment and we keep cutting out so
forgive me while we do this
as I was saying plans and elevations of
the as built structure
and some photos of the structure as
built in
context
this is showing from a wider point of
view
this is showing towards the neighboring
agricultural field
so the neighbor to the north which is
number 24 dunnington
and looking towards Heath Cottage to the
South
the officer recommendation is to Grant
Subject to conditions thank you chairman
Ryan thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is Mr Jeremy gascoigne good evening Mr
gascoigne
you certainly can we'll get them up and
while you're getting yourself settled
I'll just remind you I'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 seconds before
your time is up if you press the
I thought you'd given up
three minutes 30 second warning
as they're on their way they're on their
way don't you worry about that as soon
as they're up and you're comfortable and
ready to go if you press the button in
the middle the floor is yours
Mr chairman members of the committee I
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak I wish the Lord your strong
objection to this planning application
this is a retrospective application but
we hope that the committee will view it
as any normal application and ask the
question would this structure pass the
planning process had it not really been
built
I have some concerns about the accuracy
of the committee report and believe the
inaccuracies could be misleading
I only had the opportunity to discuss
this matter with the planning officer
yesterday lunchtime when he conducted a
site visit at the 11th Hour
this was the first time he had seen the
structure from our land and had been
given and been given a correct account
to the land and building use and other
factors relating to this application
including land ownership
I will go through the port
assessment of key issues paragraph two
yes the heath Cottage does have a wide
range for outbuildings including a
garage with a flat a boat which is about
30 meters from chicoti Cottage
this structure was built in 1950 and is
part of the heath Cottage this has
nothing to do with the development of
five houses as indicated in the report
the view the viewing platform looks
straight into the Dormer window
Associated to this building including
the toilet window
paragraph four and residential immunity
quote there are Open Fields due east
and West agreed but the report fails to
mention our private Garden 19 meters to
the southeast and a private Garden
attached to number 24 dunnington
which is the house up to the north which
is a zero beta which is zero meters from
structure
they were incorrectly called Paddock and
agricultural land
this is a total lot of privacy on our
behalf
design and distinctiveness
the planet officer I quote assumes that
the applicants
would not wish to put themselves at risk
by using the platform if it were a
dangerous structure
the applicants do not have any
Structural Engineering qualifications
and we do not have a structural report
I Quest also questioned my neighbor's
judgment and their concept of safety
when they have been using this structure
with a high voltage cable about two
meters above the floor level 30 seconds
uh in paragraph some point to the
planning statement it states that the
platform is appropriate design the rough
Timber's vertical have no design
association with the cottage whatsoever
and is more akin to a wild west Fortress
than the historic Cottage extension
it is also described in the same report
as an elected style
architecture can it be both
the so-called privacy screen does little
to prevent viewing is directly into our
private garden and flat
sign the subject however it is a header
structure that does nothing to improve
or enhance the character or either
existing Cottage or the surrounding area
in our very real setting it infringes on
our privilege Mr gas going up I'm very
sorry I'm going to have to stop you
there you you went over your time
because I couldn't get my microphones to
work
um now they're all on
sort of brilliant this Tech is wonderful
um let's try again okay so thank you
very much for that members do you have
any questions for us to gascoigne please
Council Mills
good evening um so I I've looked at the
report when when did this uh structure
go up
February this year
right thank you Council Curtis
has yours gone too
they were charged this morning oh
gold sorry sorry
thank you
um just look at page 64 of the officer
report just to clarify
um the final paragraphs is the nearest
land to the north and east is Paddock an
agricultural land respectively
are you saying that that is is actually
Garden land
Mr Gaston can you make sure your
microphone's on when you respond please
thank you
um it's not on those photographs but it
will be on our award members ones but
yes the uh to the uh North is the
um the garden even if it is badly kept
um of a ragley cottage
and to the South East
uh 19 meters away is our private Garden
right so so look straight down on top of
it so you're saying that that is
slightly misleading thank you for that
clarification I think it's worth having
that clarified by the officers as well
councilor Crump please
I apologies um yeah can I find those
distances I didn't quite have the last
one was at 90 or 19. ah vegetable garden
right and private Garden which it has
further things uh holiday for the plants
as well is uh 19 meters to the site one
nine
the ragley cottage is zero meters
because it's right on the border if not
over
okay any other questions members no in
that case Miss gasoline thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening
and we will call our uh next speaker who
is Mr Gary moss and I believe being
accompanied by the applicants as well is
that right
hello good evening
are you going to be splitting your time
you have got three minutes we did go
over 10 seconds so I do have to allow
you that extra 10 seconds uh I don't
know whether you're going to need it or
not are you planning to split your time
or one of you you'll have questions
presumably
okay in that case Mr Moss uh you'll have
three minutes and 10 seconds I'll give
you 30 second morning when you're ready
for yours
thank you very much Sharon
um firstly we'd like to
um thank the officer for his report uh
despite what has just been said there
are clear
um issues and discrepancies firstly the
land and where those photographs were
taken by the neighbor is agricultural
land it is not Paddock um it's not their
allotment or their private Garden it's
just the field they own
um going back to the officers report I'd
just like to
make a couple of points firstly the
letters of support
um which there are six actually only
come from two residences sorry the
letters of objection sorry only come
from two residences within dunnington
the others are all from far field and I
can only assume our relatives or family
friends of the objector as Heath Cottage
in contrast we have five letters of
support from residents in the immediate
area and from within the village
um in terms of the design it is an
Eclectic property as set out by the
officer but the design of the balcony is
not just been thrown up the wood is from
the ragley estate's own Sawmill the
design of the privacy screen is taken
from the design cues of ragley Hall and
its perimeter fencing as well
the use of wood is in keeping with the
rural setting of this property and also
what is used on both the existing
property and other properties in the
Amer in the immediate area
um there is another benefit as well it
does also provide a secondary means of
fire escape from the property if
um was required given it is a thatch
Cottage
um just picking up some of the points
that were raised previously by the
neighbor
um as I say firstly the land he is
referring to where those photographs
were taken is agricultural land
his garden allotment is not residential
Garden it's agricultural land being used
as allotment so it's not a private
residential Garden as he States
in terms of the structural engineer the
clients have undertaken professional
building of this and it is a structure
rightly so they would not be using it if
they didn't feel it would be supported
they've also had confirmation from
Western power there is no implications
of the structure and or its proximity to
that power line which you can see in the
photograph
overall I just want to say that the
officers report is Well written it's
clearly balanced it's taken a
professional View and also he's taken
the time to visit site visit the
surrounding areas look from the public
viewpoints and has Concord it correctly
that this development is acceptable
thank you I was just about to give you a
30 second warning but no need now uh
members any questions for either our
agent or the applicant
got some else
like Gary good to see you um Gary are
there
are there similar structures like this
throughout The Village
you said you said it's in keeping so are
there
similar structures to that
um I can't confirm that there's similar
structures in terms of
um balconies or raised structures where
I'm saying in keeping is the actual
design of it the use of the wood and the
design rationale for the privacy
screening has been taken from the ragley
estate and area there are examples wider
Fields as the example of arrays platform
in bidford on Avon overlooking the river
and like with many properties that I've
seen it's similar to a balcony in accent
but it is a freestanding structure but
whether there's other properties in the
village maybe the African be able to
confirm Hills Farm Shop can I ask you to
turn your microphone on while you're
speaking thank you uh headless Farm Shop
you know we've taken
um a you know a real interest in our IR
area we've lived there for 26 years and
it's our home we don't want to make a
mess of it we love where we live and we
love our views
um sorry about my nerves
um yeah so it's really important to us
you know it's our forever home we're not
going anywhere
um our neighbor might like us to go but
we're not going anywhere
um and uh
the views that we have we our garden
goes to the one side so the the back of
our Cottage is our beautiful view when
we bought it
um previously only said to us I'm very
I'm very sorry I'm going to cut across
you now because at the moment you're not
answering the question you're pitching
and uh
thank you uh did you speak to your
neighbors about this um prior to putting
up or during any point just signing
um our relationship has become very
um
um fractured to be fair since
um his parents died and he bought the
property and then developed wanted to
develop it for five homes
um our relationship has become very
um
you know fractured unfortunately
cancer Crump yes dude I spoke to the uh
sorry the neighbor of 24 and he was he
did not have a problem with it if that's
what you meant sorry and we do have
relationship with them
picking the report
in a kind of A Private Matter I spoke in
that respect
um
well we didn't actually
um think because it's not integral into
the home it was outside we thought it
was like a garden structure that's what
we thought we believed that we could do
talking to an art
had Mr Mark Carl go around at his house
that they said we needed planning
anyone else have any questions gosh this
one's really loud isn't it
okay in that case no further questions
thank you very much to you both your
time contribution of course your
patience as well
okay let's move to our final speaker who
is councilor Bill Fleming Council
Fleming come on down thank you for your
patience
um you know the drill you've got five
minutes and 10 seconds I'll give you a
30 second warning before your time is up
feel free to use as much of that time as
you wish
um when you're settled and ready press
button in the middle and the floor is
yours
[Music]
good evening members thanks very much
for this opportunity to speak
um
this structure was built with no
registered plans or drawings or
certified calculations there's no
construction plan no risk assessment or
method statement on its design
there was no communication by the
applicant or indeed the officer
strangely enough until yesterday at
lunch time before during or after the
extension which supports the platform or
indeed the platform itself was completed
this Platforms in the Arden special
landscape area
totally inappropriate in the SLA and has
an overbear in nature on the neighbor's
private Garden
the structure which supports a platform
also has no agreed specification to
confirm it can support the platform and
people on it it has never been subject
to any building reg checks
I'm astonished the officer satisfied
with the design and appearances accepted
with its surroundings
is this acceptable on open Countryside
on two sides I'm not so sure
the officer's report is quoted direct
overlooking of a private guard is not
considered acceptable horse just a few
meters away approximately 20 to The Far
Side of the garden you could easily
distinguish carrots and cabbages on that
from that platform what's in that gut
vegetable patch
there are electricity cables to a pole
adjacent to the platform approximately
two meters above the platform
these carry four 15 volt three-phase
power sufficient to kill if touched
a wet Timber deck and power cables don't
really Belong Together
um the pole cannot be moved due to the
way leaves and the adjacent adjacent
positioning of the seven-trent main
Water Act pipeline
this platform was subject to an
enforcement visit on the 4th of May this
year
and the residents were advised on the
5th of the 5th 2002 that are planning
application could not be supported the
enforcement officer left Coke on
contacted me straight away after that
happened
I completely disagree with the officer's
report in this application that it
Accords with cs9 CS5 and cs20 as a core
strategy
cs9 paragraph one says ensuring
attractive and high quality
architectural design really
it's really the design we should be even
considering granting there is a very
limited palette designed to give any
coherence to the overall design
just because this is on the edge of open
Countryside does not mean that poor
design and construction becomes
acceptable actually could you stick my
my slide up as well please
CS5 States the rural character the
district will be maintained and enhanced
don't see how this complies at all and
therefore the officer's statement is
technically incorrect
if this had come forward as a planned
application in its current form it would
have failed just because it's
retrospective like the structure
supports it does not give it extra
weight and should be judged as a
separate application
cs20
why was this quoted I just don't see the
need the only possible reason is 5.6.3
to realize the potential of the property
however if this reason is quoted it goes
on to say it must strike an appropriate
balance by protecting the neighbors and
of neighboring residents and the
character of the locality this platform
does not apply
so sign me up cs9 I don't think it
complies CS5 I don't think it complies
cs20 don't think it complies it's a pure
design it's an unsightly construction
from wherever you look at it it's
overlooking a private Garden we've had
that disputed but it is a private Garden
it's a wooden construction for people
use it no consultation with the workshop
foreign rescue service
the overhead power cable is two meters
above
this is a this is a potential killer
situation
and the other question is does that
narrow State spiral narrow spiral
staircase allow fast enough evacuation
in the case of a fire
thank you very much
that's a Fleming thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for councilor Fleming please
Council Curtis
thank you thank you councilor um you
mentioned some enforcement action
um could you would you you spoke quite
quickly to get through everything could
you just um go over that
um again please yes certainly uh the
enforcement officer was out there on the
4th of May
um and he replied uh and copied me in on
a letter on the 5th of May
which said that uh enforcement action
would be taken
um but he he did advise the uh the
resident that they could apply for a
planning permission for it because it
required planning permission
um but he said that at that time he said
this would not be supported if you
submitted a plan application
I don't have the actual letter with me
but I can you know
you know so so from that perspective
that's what I know any other questions
councilor Parry please
thank you good evening councilor firming
um
would I I just wonder whether you can
advise
are you objecting to the principle of
the platform
or the current design of its
construction
or both
or if it was using other materials that
was in
that perhaps was more in keeping with
the existing building would you still be
objecting to it
being sort of installed in the first
place without sort of submitting any
plans and the overlooking part of it is
a concern but it just is so unsightly
um claiming that it's in keeping I mean
I've driven around I mean I lived two
miles away I've driven down dunnington
many many times through to bidford
through Broome and I've never seen
anything like it to say that it Compares
or is coherent you know it's congruent
with other stuff that's within the
village I really don't see it I think
it's
personally it's ugly I think if it came
in as a separate application
um then I I really don't think if it was
submitted in its current form that it
would be passed so I object to the fact
that it was constructed without any
permissions at all and I object to the
fact of how it actually looks
I just can remind you that it has been
submitted in its current form because
that is exactly what we're looking at
now
any other questions members
no in that case cancel filming thank you
very much for your time patience and
contribution this evening
okay let's move to points of
clarification uh before I bring in
cancer Dixon we do have one that has
been raised earlier on so um there's
debate over the uh designation of the
land behind the property is it
residential or is it agricultural
thank you chairman
I'll bring up the block plan which will
give a better idea
so you will see that the
um land is defined with the line along
here and it comes to the edge of the
stable block
we have assessed that is an agricultural
field in use
from what we can see part of the
Agricultural field is being used as a
vegetable garden but the lawful use of
the land is Agricultural and not a
garden
so just be clear if it were being used
as a garden that would be an unlawful
use correct thank you
Council Dixon
got a choice now
okay it's all good stuff isn't it
absolutely looking at the map I can see
it's gone again mate
oh you're right dive in sorry I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna say to the members
of the public and anyone watching at
home this is frightfully embarrassing
for us
um we have begun the procurement process
to get new microphones so don't think
that we're ignoring the fact that they
are painful it is embarrassing we're
doing the best with what we've got it
will change and we'll get demonstrably
better sorry Council Dick's names you no
problem I was just wondering if the
officers had viewed the uh the site at
all any photographs at all from the
public footpath so I can see one which
is on the map swinging down from
Donington here th there coming down to
the black dot and there's one roughly
heading north from the court
Etc not sure exactly what those
distances are but they are public
footpaths on this map so there's a
viewpoints to be seen from the public
area viewing through to that which I
agree with the ward member is definitely
an ugly site but uh any views from the
public footpaths
[Music]
thank you
thank you councilor so yes the the two
main constraints was obviously uh from
wider footpath paths so obviously the
footpath
um indicated by my arrow
um is marked at around 460 meters to the
east of the site and I also do have a
photo
um from that footpath which I'll get up
now for you
foreign
facing towards the application site
Ryan thank you very much on the plus
side my new microphone the internal uh
speaker is now working so I can hear you
a lot clearer which is great
um anyone else got any questions
Council Harley
yes could I ask the officer there was a
reference by Mr Gaskill
um
recently
I presume that visit was made after your
report was written
is there any change you or addition
you'd want to make to your report as a
result of that visit
um yeah the case officer has
the case officer has visited the site
prior to writing the report they were
satisfied on visiting the site on the
first occasion or occasions that there
was enough information to make a
professional assessment of what the
proposal was yesterday's visit was a
supplementary one to obtain a picture
for the benefit of members tonight of
the views from the neighboring land uh
because we didn't feel we'd covered at
all
this officer has visited it prior to
writing the report thank you very much
that's very helpful
my just results are shouting and that
might be the okay
um any more questions points of
clarification now let's move to debate
who'd like to kick us off
cancer Curtis
oh kick off chair
um yes looking at policy CS5 cs9
enduring high quality and so ensuring
high quality design
I'm not sure I'm this it is subjective
but in my subjective view I don't really
feel that this is high quality design
and Landscape character and enhancement
policy CS5
visual impact you know
preserving the local distinctiveness and
historic character and
to
confirms with either of those um
policies
Curtis Castle Mills please
chairman actually announced Curtis
Morely civil I was going to say but it's
just not not in keeping uh with a local
area I think even the applicant um said
so
um it just doesn't fit in Mr chairman so
um I will be going against obvious
recommendation on this thank you thanks
so much I should have checked with you
cancer cases beforehand are you formally
proposing a refusal
yes I think on those those two grounds
those policy CS5 and cs9 thank you very
much Council Mills just to confirm are
you seconding that yes I'll second that
Mr marvelous thank you very much anyone
else have anything they want to say
no okay uh
officers
um are you content that the reasons that
have been given for refusal will
stand up to scrutiny
um yeah I'm content that members of of
Justified why they feel that it's
contrary to CS5 on landscape ground and
cs9 on designing distinctiveness grounds
on the grounds that it's not in keeping
uh with the character of the area
okay lovely uh in that case uh let's
move unless anyone else have anything to
say we'll move to a vote so the proposal
is to refuse application 2202 370 ful
for the reasons given you could have a
show of hands version favor of the
refusal
nine ten
and against
and abstentions one committee therefore
resolves to refuse application twenty
two zero two three seven zero fuel
teaser cozy cottage in Ulster do we have
any urgent business
I'm gonna assume that's a no in that
case ladies and gentlemen members
officers thank you very much for your
time and contributions this evening and
we will see you in a couple of weeks
meeting is closed